how's it going there reject nation thank
you so much for clicking on this video
we're going to do something pretty
experimental here today we have not seen
each other's lists first thing i'm going
to say i haven't seen each other's list
but i was like you know i imagine that
one day there's going to be people who
are like hey let's do an american remake
of squid game i know it's easy to roll
your eyes out of gawk at and honestly
when i first was like pitching this idea
to john i wasn't thinking this but
eventually you know i haven't seen
john's list yet but by the time i got to
my list i was like actually
this would be pretty cool
you might not be you will be like no i
mean overall i'm like you probably
shouldn't do it most likely you probably
shouldn't but who knows maybe one of us
might be able to open your guys's eyes
and do an american remake of squid game
there will probably be some spoilers in
here but all right john i'm just so
curious to know what you got to say so
let's let's uh let's have you go first
but okay so for mine this is gonna be
set in the states because you know
american remake we got to bring it home
but it'll still be kind of multicultural
i want it to be you know a broadcast so
the first character obviously gehen
start with our protagonist i deliberated
over this a little bit there was one
person i really wanna cast and i
ultimately went against that choice of
owen wilson what i finally arrived at my
casting for gihon would be steven yun
because i think that he's got that every
man quality he can be kind of roughed up
and down on his luck but he can also be
very sweet and very charismatic and very
endearing and i feel like he is at the
right age bracket getting a little bit
older than you know from what we
associated with on the walking dead now
is the time where he's trying to prove a
little bit more of his dramatic chops
and i think it would be interesting to
see him play a character that is also
not as strong at the core at the start
of something so that's who i'm going
with for this one
okay for like all the reasons you said
or why i have my choice okay uh of an
actor who's especially improving his
dramatic chops as of late and putting
himself out there with versatility
someone could have a bit of that like
also likable affable quality and also be
an underdog
so for gihan i would choose chris pratt
i think chris pratt in particular would
i mine would still be said in korea by
the way i could set this to america i
think for korea he would be perfect
because he's an international star and i
feel like part of the problem with squid
game was that he was an unknown and i
think having a major superstar in there
would help elevate the material and he's
got that like just imagine when he's
like thrusted into the position and he
does that familiar bewildered look that
chris pratt does
and i make him more of a lead too you
know like i i probably you know pump up
the the gas on the ark like a red light
green light he would start leading
everyone yeah he would play them
together right i imagine chris power
probably asked for that too so i'd
rather just get it out of the way in the
writing but that's who i would choose
for a gihon who i personally think is a
stronger choice than stephen john
you know i sh yeah you're probably right
but who do you got next uh we got let's
go with sung woo let's let's work our
way down the chain of prominence in
terms of impact and the team you know
sangwoo is a straight-laced character i
haven't renamed everybody yet but he's a
guy with a big education and a lot of
status but also a lot of darkness
beneath that a lot of things to hide so
he can be very affable and very charming
when he needs to be or at least you know
sort of sensible seeming but there's
also that percolating darkness at the
core uh and i think joseph gordon-levitt
would be a great choice for that kind of
like stephen young he's growing up a
little bit into more mature roles
heavier roles a little bit more the man
joseph gordon-levitt than the boy i feel
like kind of like leonardo dicaprio he's
been trapped as a boy for a long time he
and stephen young are also kind of close
i think in age range and so song woo
knowing uh gihon growing up i think they
would be a good kind of back and forth
between them
that's true i mean first off uh i my
character names i'm gonna keep them all
the same uh i think just you know
branding recognition authenticity it's
important yeah it really helps you know
ip recognition so all my characters are
gonna be named the same still okay um
but yeah i was thinking of a guy too who
um has like you said a percolating
darkness within him someone who also
like saying was like really smart like
that was a big part of someone who went
to like seoul uh it was a seoul
university i think or or the phoenix
state university seoul it's devry the
broad no you're messing with me sorry i
won't i'll take this seriously so it's
uh with seoul and i was like which actor
can really bring
that heft that also wouldn't be
distracting and perhaps can play up some
of the manipulation quality so that's
why i for saying woo i chose seth rogen
i think seth rogen has really shown a
lot more of his dramatic work as of late
jobs
um
he's good in jobs and
you know like that character who can
also uh you know like you trust at first
you see he's smart but you know he can
also like trick you i mean imagine like
when they're doing the the the the one
with the shapes he would be like home
game i
i'm going with the triangle but you
should probably go in an easier one for
your gut go with umbrella you know you
believe him uh-huh and i think he would
bring the right like best friend you can
trust quality yes i i have to agree with
you
all right well why don't we move on from
there to the most beloved character out
of this whole thing and i deliberated
very hard and it's funny because i
looked at other fan castings so as to
not overlap too hard there's one actor i
would have loved to have chosen from the
the season of hill house number two i'm
forgetting the title of but the ultimate
one i landed on is a bit of a curveball
i would love to see oscar isaac
jump into a completely sympathetic role
because oscar isaac lately he gets
thrust into these who as ali okay we're
talking about ali sorry i'm talking
talking about how great my choice is
yeah of course i'm i'm excited to hear
it cause it's probably gonna blow mine
out of the water but i think oscar isaac
has the vulnerability and he has that
warmth he can access it i feel like he
gets tapped to play a lot of characters
who are stern or tough or have some kind
of darkness and coldness but i feel like
that does exist within him and for me
right now even though he is a big name i
would love to see him embody a character
that is
so compassionate and so trusting and see
how he breaks our hearts with that he's
not of uh pakistani descent you know
obviously borrowing from a slightly
different set of politics you know that
character left pakistan to pursue
opportunity in korea uh oscar iii has uh
south american descent so you know
coming from that angle being set in
america you know i feel like you could
create perhaps politically different but
also still salient parallels
interesting choice
i'm not sure how i feel about it yeah
why don't you guys decide what's
absolutely yeah
it's funny because ali is my favorite
character too in the show but i feel
like for very different reasons
like
i think about ollie you know he's
shorter than everyone else
he's
he's short he's shorter than everyone
else he seems like really fast that's a
big part he's like a big ball of energy
so that's why for ali i would choose
charlie day
who is a pakistani descent if i'm not
mistaken so i'm staying true to the
roots i know a lot of mine has been kind
of race swapping but i want to keep this
one um sincere and accurate considering
all he's my favorite absolutely and so i
think charlie day imagined him being
kind of like scratch from ice age uh
when they're playing like red like like
green light
yeah
that's all he's energy yeah or when the
prison riots happening
he's like oh god everyone's killing
that's all we're gonna do
yeah totally i feel like this would also
be a chance for charlie day to showcase
some more of his dramatic chops
definitely
so charlie day i would say ali pakistani
actor charlie day
great
good representation there i'm glad that
you did some diverse casting
at some point here uh let's move on to i
know your other favorite character
definitely out of the series and one of
everyone's favorite female leads menyo
whose name i'm probably butchering you
know i am going to be a heathen and
rename all of these for my remake but
there was only one name that came to
mind for some reason to this role and i
think she would be perfect because when
she plays wily
and manipulative characters i think she
can access the same sort of
off-the-leash wild unpredictable energy
and that is julianne moore i think she's
going back home i think she thinks i
could really see that finally thank you
nice sincerely i can see that it was the
first name that came to mind and i can
just i can just see it when it's in my
mind's eye i'm like she would be perfect
she would have that crazy unpredictable
energy and when it's time for her to
really make some harsh moves that grip
you yeah you know i think she would have
everybody's attention
you know
surprisingly this was a really hard one
for me to do when i was first looking at
um hi surname mino
that's not gonna work that's my guess
when i would first imagine the character
i was like i guess i could maybe see
even like a
maybe even like an anne hathaway
or something like that right
a good uh
good engineer good traumatic actress it
was when i saw the dub
when it clicked for me just like who is
a woman who was just so annoying
in this business that's why i'm going
with katherine heigl oh good i think
catherine heigl and the reputation she's
sort of generated for herself over the
years
as this difficult to work with actress
and uh seems to come and she is getting
older and you know the way how uh what's
her name mean you wow that is not gonna
land i'm gonna rewrite that character's
name
so do your thing the way how catherine
heigl embodies this the the the
frustration of an actress who should be
more grateful and is probably very
insecure and that's why she takes it out
on people manipulates her way into the
roles i would go to catherine heigl
for mulan on this one i know house i i
don't want to taint your opinion but i
feel like if she could access that level
of insanity it might be pretty
compelling so so not bad well i'm
changing the background where she's
playing katherine heigl oh she's playing
herself she's essentially going to play
herself
it's a satire it's a commentary okay
sure
please continue why not let's go uh to
some people's favorite heartthrob on the
show
the beautiful number 67 saab yoke pocket
uh-huh everyone loves her i deliberated
hard over this there were a couple
people that came to mind i know a lot of
the fan castings were you know i'm not
even gonna say because i don't know what
you're gonna say and i know this is
serious business so uh one name that
came to mind i thought maybe like i feel
like jennifer lawrence could do this but
i i want to see somebody else who's a
little younger and who can really embody
that anger and that quiet uh hurt that
that character has who can really be
introverted but in a very compelling way
to watch and funny enough even though i
haven't seen her in a million things uh
them in a million things storm reid i
think could do that role especially
after watching storm reading especially
no four uh the suicide squad most
recently but like a wrinkle and tie
she's much younger in a wrinkle in time
but she's bloodsport's daughter in the
suicide squad
scene that she has with him and you know
even in the brief moments outside of
that scene i was like yeah i still
believe all that backstory that you have
here and you have a lot of presence even
though you're a small moment in this
movie and so i feel like she could
embody that compelling sort of silence
like what's going on under there like
there's something you know i need to
know more about this character kind of
energy and i think too bringing that
compassion to her little brother and all
that stuff i think she would really uh
be able to nail all that
yes you need an actor who can provide
quite a variety especially one who like
she has the role cyborg of more like uh
i love those body language roles where
it's like all in the eyes and reserved
and dark but then you do find out that
there is a compassionate angle to them
like you were saying so when really
going through my list there was only one
person who really stuck the landing for
me so for psyog i would choose zach
galifianakis
i think
zach galifianak is what are you laughing
about i'm sorry i was thinking of
something unrelated i'm so jubilee
i had so many expectations for this one
uh but i think zach galifianakis if
you've seen him in anything you see that
he can also like he's so compelling when
he's being quiet but you can feel
there's there's a side of him that can
be kind of intimidating like sheltered
but has a presence yeah i feel like zach
galifianakis
just has all the qualities like when i'm
seeing symbiote honestly there were
times watching squid game where i'm like
i'm having a hard time not seeing zach
galifianakis
you know it crossed my mind the timer
too also yeah yeah but uh who do you got
on your list oh next well hey let's go
to the opposite end of the spectrum
let's go with a scoundrel dioxu a
character character right
and this was the hardest one i think for
me to cast because i think there are
people yes there are a couple choices
where i'm like i would absolutely want
to see this person this person and this
person take it on adrian brody first
came to mind but i was like you know
what i want somebody a little more broad
in the character because this guy is a
slimy guy you know he is not only just a
gangster but he's a bit of a low life
too and so it came down neck and neck to
me between john leguizamo or benicio del
toro ooh both good friends and i think
ultimately
i might in this day and age go with
benicio just because he can do the whole
range although leguizamo i think has
just that perfect level of like he can
play interesting and nuanced but also a
slime
so uh that's that was a really hard one
to deliberate between these aren't bad
choices at all i like how diverse your
casts turn out to be thank you um but i
think that when you're especially if
you're saying it in like korea for like
for mine you want to keep the race
consistent so absolutely um oh how do
you pronounce this character's name
again duck sue duck sue okay so for duck
sue same thing of what you were saying
you know someone who is kind of
slimy and i was like who's like a slimy
controversial figure someone who would
just like betray you just for their own
benefit right like what actor can really
embody that and who has a light because
he has a very specific look kind of
heavy a little bit longer hair and
that's why i went with jay leno
i think jay leno after the events that
took place with conan o'brien i'm like
guys he's practically doxxu in real life
he is he jumped off the bridge to avoid
conan at one point yeah he's essentially
him
and he even kind of looks like him a lot
the features are similar can you imagine
that snake tat on his chin
yeah i mean that'd be crazy i mean can
you imagine jay leno and catherine heigl
having uh relations in the battle i want
did not have to imagine it i want to see
it i feel like it would lead more of an
impact than the original squid game to
be honest so i think jay leno definitely
has
like just the real life qualities of
naksu yeah he's lived yeah he wouldn't
have to build much of a character and he
probably owes a lot of people money i
just yeah
yeah yeah he can drive one of his fancy
cars to set
all right well then let's move on
outside of the game now what what about
um let's see june ho
gotcha very cool character very calm and
collected character very competent
character you need somebody who's young
he seems like he's a
young detective out of all the things in
squid game he's probably the most cool
thing uh so you need an actor who's like
kind of cool but can still play that
sort of silent like i get [ __ ] done sort
of vibe and i went kind of off the
beaten path for this one i i deliberated
hard because nobody really came directly
to mind and i also thought okay i gotta
also link this guy uh to the front man
and i had a better idea of who i thought
the front man might be so uh for june ho
i am casting an actor named manish dayal
who i know uh as a guest star on agents
of shield but he's done a bunch of other
things too again young guy who looks
like he could fill a similar kind of
role as this detail like i'd buy him if
he was like yeah you know i'm trying to
unravel some kind of crime conspiracy
and also you know having at least a
little personality to make him seem like
a compassionate character underneath
mostly just a bunch of badass action he
gets to do
okay i mean the qualities of the front
man uh i mean i talk about the tech
but i want to know like beforehand like
just can you just tell me like who is
your front man because i mean the
quality of the front men are pretty
obvious but who is your front man
because they have to play the brother
right uh-huh yeah so who is he my front
man is risa med
rizz ahmed interesting choice why where
is ahmed uh because he much like uh
uh uh i know his name damn
hyun lee uh he has a certain status as
an actor that precedes him so that when
the mask comes off you're like oh it's
you and he also has a lot of presence he
can you know be very gripping and stern
i feel like he would have to maybe bulk
up a little bit because he's kind of a
skinny guy but uh i feel like he could
easily be that guy's brother maybe of a
couple years older and also carry a
certain like you know i could see how
these guys are cut of similar cloth but
also how this guy is of a much more
intense stripe now yes okay so for me my
choice is for uh junhoe and the front
man
for john hoe i was thinking the same
thing someone who could be like kind of
sneaky stealthy might look like a really
nice guy at first but really is actually
can be a threat when necessary
and neil patrick harris was the first
person that came to mind for me i think
the great thing about neil patrick
harris is that whenever you see him on
screen you don't see neil patrick harris
no you i almost cast him in one of these
other roles you only see the character
that he's playing now a gone girl all i
saw was that character the matrix
resurrections trailer i freak i was like
oh wait that's neil patrick i never i
see past the harold and kumar films all
the time the harold and kumar films even
there so then i thought okay but the
frontman has to be his brother
who
can embody kind of that stoic presence
underneath the mask and also looks like
neil patrick harris so for the front man
i'm going with tilda swinton i think
tilda swinton just looks the most like
neil patrick harris
out of any other actor i could think of
more than even that guy in malcolm in
the middle i think tilda swinton really
she hasn't had an opportunity to take
over a role yet that was uh originally
designed for a man so i think that'll be
interesting to see the kind of
personalities that both neil patrick
harris and till this women bring are
very similar
and i think they're acting if you look
at their roles you could really just
swap them out uh with each other and
they'd pretty much be the same thing so
i feel like they're just a perfect fit
until the swinton's just more in
intimidating than neil patrick harris
just the right quality you can get older
brother vibes from tilda swinton i think
she is more intimidating yeah than neil
patrick harris yes for certain good good
match a good a good match there but now
the big one the big one one more left
who's behind it all and who is also
so lovable
so curious to know who you got i
deliberated hard on this one and i feel
like this is going to be my most off the
rails take interest for this because i
thought of you know like especially in
the states i'm like who are some of our
older actors who are kind of i don't
want to say ancient but who are like you
know very much getting on in years but
who can also be very lovable who can
also bring you in and really make you
hurt and feel for them and then who can
also make you feel like oh you do have
the capacity for this whole twisted
thing and i thought man somebody like a
clint eastwood has the age factor and
maybe some of the warmth factor but you
know who's got the crazy when it counts
and who could also probably throw you
off during the dementia moments and who
also has that toothy grin is christopher
walken i think if you shaved his head or
you cut his hair short and you actually
had him in a mode to bring a performance
and not just
me
squid game if you had him bring a true
performance i think that could be
because by the end he has to be able to
command that heaviness of presence and
to be like wow you really i can see how
you did all this and i think he's got
the spectrum for both
interesting
and he's you know he's getting pretty
old now i actually thought you were
going to say alan arkin for a second
oh that would be good
yeah
that's not what you chose that's not
what i chose like wow because alan arkin
was probably like second person and i
really thought you were leading there i
gotta tell you i'm i'm kicking myself
for not going tobin bell on this one
it's right there i was like okay who
could be better than allen oregon and i
was thinking about all the qualities of
this this old man who decided to take
this adventure in life just because he's
he's old and he's got nothing else
better to do by this point he's bored
you feel sorry for him might have some
type of like mental conditions he's
dealing with due to physical ailments as
well your lovable grandpa character but
you can tell there's suspicious there's
something suspicious about him that
might not be as lovable as his put on
the forefront and that's why for ill nom
i'm going with joe biden
i think president joe biden especially
the character
you know like when you think about that
dementia scene too when they're playing
the marbles game it's kind of like makes
you think of the debates a little bit
right and so
i think joe biden funny enough maybe we
should make sure donald trump fall right
so yes
let's just make it the entire 2020
electoral electoral race
from my great dark studio
give me your egg why don't i only get
one egg
i'm gonna put you underground
people and it's probably a lot of money
yeah
donald trump's probably a better friend
uncle joe i can see it
joe biden you know just like it was face
dude probably it's like oh my god oh my
god it's only so many years to live
a little bored let me run for president
and uh sometimes people might not think
i'm present all the time
and i just feel like
this is what i do on presidential
vacations like i'm here if you're like
ill mommy why don't make a great own mom
i think you're correct i can i want that
version i want to see it um
so yeah guys i i i think uh those are
the picks those are the pick i mean we
we should next time we should cast the
vips we should we should i was thinking
donald trump junior
ivanka
jared kushner
steve bannon
all those guys
yeah
yeah man scaramucci where's uh where's
your boy crowder where's the guy who
didn't kill himself put him in there
where's epstein
but guys you know augustine does love
this quick game that's our list uh my
film would be directed
by
the man
the rock keeps working with oh ross and
marshall thurber yeah the director of
jungle cruise oh no joe mccall is sarah
that guy yeah
i forget what he's done and yeah it's a
good horror movie and then a lot of
blockbusters
and uh i would get freeberg and seltzer
to be co-writing this with alex kurtzman
and
yeah totally definitely so yeah guys
javia rod's going to produce it bobby
rob would produce it yeah it's going to
be good so this is just where i'm at i'd
also i think a show was too long i'd
make it probably a two-hour movie uh so
shave it to 90 minutes man no fat you
gotta have some breathing
so make it like a two-hour movie but
yeah guys between our picks which ones
do you think would work best subscribe
click that notification bell once you go
ahead hit that like button
and hey we'll catch you guys soon thanks
so much for being here spread the word
about this video because when they do
the inevitable casting i want to get
credit i want to know to give credits i
want to get credit
[Music]